the oe refrigerator is a fridge that
combines the european aesthetics with
the chinese feature benefits now this
fridge aims to be sitting in the living
room the flex store of the fridge
actually allows for customization so
that consumers can actually play around
with the interior
one of the things that we really wanted
to do was differentiate ourselves
visually so that consumers can see our
product from a distance this was done
with the creation of the curved glass
door and the rounded corners we used
glass instead of metal to represent the
door fronts and this was aimed to make
it more interior fit with the consumers
homes and not just an object that was
placed anywhere in the kitchen
the brief was given to us from our
marketing team and with that brief we
actually worked with the r d department
the marketing department as well as the
design department we've kind of looked
at what are the
constraints that we have in the product
and how we would then work around those
constraints from a creation in terms of
a concept right up to a finished product
the biggest challenges when designing
the user interface is when working on
the proximity sensor how do we actually
design the proximity sensor so that it
looks discrete and beautiful from a
distance without sacrificing or
compromising the performance sensing
performance
it is very encouraging to see that
singapore recognizes designs and
designers that are from singapore it
raises the bar of design standards in
singapore and allowing more mncs to
really come into singapore and at least
recognize the contribution that we can
give to the global community
my advice to emerging designers would be
to have a keen sense of observation and
that can help you create new and
interesting ideas for future
this is the oe refrigerator design of
the year
you